there is a stunning double standard that
I want to talk about today would this
idea of leave the USA if you don't like
it which Donald Trump has started
talking about more and more lately and
at the same time Donald Trump has a
different message for immigrants from
other countries where he says no no if
there are problems in your country if
there are things you don't like in your
country you shouldn't come to the US you
should stay there and fix those problems
so let me reset this for you so we all
know what I'm talking about here I told
you last week that Donald Trump's latest
slogan love it or leave it about people
who don't like things that are happening
in the United States is straight out of
the KKK is 1970s PlayBook there were
billboards in all sorts of places where
the Ku Klux Klan would use this slogan
in the 1970s in North Carolina also in
other states love it or leave it and it
was about being against communism and I
forget the other intention that it had
but it was relevant to the politics at
the time that the KKK was getting behind
Trump has adopted this slogan and this
idea now and he's increasingly taking
the approach that if the ethnic minority
democratic congresswoman or whoever
aren't pleased with something that's
going on in the United States they
should just move to another country that
they like better they don't need to try
to change the United States love it or
leave it if you don't like it then just
go somewhere else but then at the same
time when Donald Trump is faced with the
reality that we have many immigrants who
are coming to the United States fleeing
their home countries seeking asylum his
view becomes completely different oh no
they shouldn't fall under the leave it
love it or leave it umbrella if they
don't like what's going on in their home
country they should stay there and fix
the problems of their country so that
then their country would be better and
they would no longer be interested in
coming to the United States that's
exactly what people are trying to do
here in the United States right Trump
says immigrants should fix their home
countries rather than go to a different
country it would be immigrants to the
United States let me say it a different
way foreigners should stay in their home
countries and try to fix them rather
than coming to the United States well
that's what people in the United States
are trying to do and you're telling them
if you don't like what's going on
here go somewhere else when we call for
changing our immigration policy we're
trying to fix our country to say if you
don't like it go somewhere else is
antithetical to what this country was
founded on we want to change the health
care system here so that we can live
here and have healthier people and
people who can work in ways that are not
impacted by whether they're going to
lose health insurance at mediocre as it
might be by quitting their job we're
staying in our country and trying to
change it but in those cases Trump's
advice is go to Europe or go to some
other place that has the health care
system that you're describing no this is
the entire point we want to improve the
country we're not trying to bail out and
go somewhere else
so this fundamentally comes down to yet
another one of these double standards I
know that why even mention it at this
point the Republican Party under Trump
has become completely immune to double
standards no one could possibly support
Trump if they cared about double
standards so we've got to go beyond that
this is about how politics works okay if
we allowed this narrative of if you
don't if you have so many complaints why
don't you just leave if we allow that to
become valid political discourse we are
allowing one of the fundamental roles of
politics to be perverted the reason
people vote in elections the reason we
have elections is so that if you're not
happy with what's taking place here you
can change it okay there are so many
ideas that this president pushes that
are fundamentally anti-american we've
talked about most of them threats to the
press recently saying he would take help
from Russia or China in 2020 sure why
not the way we're treating asylum
seekers it's all anti-american but one
of the most anti-american ideas that's
been flowing out of this White House's
collective mouth is the idea that if you
don't like what's happening here you
should leave and go elsewhere there's
nothing more American than being an
activist for the type of country you
want to have and I'll go even further
Donald Trump spent Barack Obama's
presidency slamming Obama about all the
things that were wrong with the United
States of America he ran on making
America great again by change
it from Obama's America by his own logic
right
he should be leaving if he doesn't like
it he didn't like it under Obama he
should have left instead he ran for
president and won so of course it's a
talking point of course it's ignorant
rhetoric from the White House love it or
leave it but it is so fundamentally
anti-american that we can't give him an
inch on this one don't like it leave no
it's if you don't like it you try to
change it just like Trump did in 2016
just like we've been doing for hundreds
of years so it's really important help
me on this one we cannot allow the love
it or leave it idea I know the slogan is
cartoonishly a KKK slogan revitalized by
Donald Trump as he has done with so many
nationalist slogans and and mottos over
the over the last couple of years I
understand that the idea of it cannot be
allowed to infiltrate American politics
because it is so destructive and so
anti-american make sure you give us a
like on Facebook at facebook.com slash
David Pakman show approaching 100,000
likes on Facebook which the kids these
days tell me no longer matters the kids
are all off Facebook now but apparently
two people my age Facebook is still sort
of cool so anyway give us a like their
quick break back after this